My name is Adjoa Anne Bernadette Konin.
I like Dakar a lot.
There is a great deal of solidarity, which can’t be measured.
We are all together; we are one big family with children and everything.
I am a nurse at the FANN Hospital in Dakar.
I like this job because I like helping people.
During the pandemic, it was really really hard
for the Senegalese people. For everyone.
We can’t forget that.
Because we lost many people, lots of relatives, friends, neighbours.
It had a big impact on us.
There are a lot of people who have been vaccinated,
but there are still others who are going around without a vaccination.
It might be a good idea to work with the Africans and all that so that we can have more medicines.
With that we can fight the disease.
We can take precautions and get ahead of it.
It will be really good for me to see that.